welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston let's break down Marvel's Loki
season 1 episode 3 lamentis ahead of
Loki season two we are doing a Loki
season one re-watch and we were able to
find even more details in Easter eggs
and this video is sponsored by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes launching your own website a
breeze there's actually a lot going on
in this momentous episode trust me let's
give this episode The Fresh perspective
it deserves and figuring out what
they're really going for by having these
two Star-Crossed variants come together
in a doomed City on lamentis and a
pretty impressive unbroken tracking shot
okay we open on Haley kyoko's song
Demons playing over the Marvel title
[Music]
of course the lyrics speaking to the
conspiracy theory that really courses
through this whole series and how the
employees of the TBA cannot trust the
TBA for wiping their memories as we
learn this episode all TBA employees are
past variants including Hunter C20 here
who cannot trust these memories with
Sylvie because she is invading them and
using them against her we all also hear
the lyric from demons please forgive me
I got demons in my head because yeah
Sylvie is the demon in c20's head or
really is the demon in her head someone
named
these fruity drinks in this constructive
memory by Sylvie and it's pretty cool to
see her witchcraft at work like this
from the subjective view it's kind of a
localized version of what Wanda Maxima
puts people through in Westview and we
should never forget that Wanda and
Agatha and Sylvie are all kind of
color-coded witches using the same kind
of hexes and I just noticed the exterior
of this restaurant which looks pretty
surreal the color is a shade of lavender
kind of like lamentis one but a Lake
Tahoe like location yeah they are
wearing the same kind of clothes you'd
wear at a beach resort or a Suburban TGI
Fridays Sylvie explains what brain
freeze is it permeates the roof of your
mouth and freezes the synapses in your
brain so your memories are literally
Frozen in place yes this whole episode
of lamentis is a brain Frozen memory
Time Frozen in place Sophie begins
drinking with C20 in the middle of the
episode she's gonna be in a bar with a
drunken Loki in a location that she
knows from past experience is a doomed
lament that she can never Escape c20's
drink is only half full whereas Sylvie
has barely touched hers which is always
a tell in spy movies when one person is
drinking and the other isn't that
something nefarious is going on in this
case the witch seducing a mark to invade
her thoughts but I love this the mugs
that they drink out of are actually from
Trader Sam's Enchanted Tiki Bar at the
Disneyland Resort there are the glasses
at the hippopotamatai is served in now
we find out later that this memory of
c20s was from hundreds of years prior
from her past as a human on earth before
she became a variant which explains why
she was repeating it was real it was
real after coming out of that
enchantment this was based on a real
memory that she had had and hundreds of
years tells us that the TVA technology
is really grounded in 31st Century
architecture another clue that this is
all the doing of a Kang but after this
switch the music is now different it's
ladytron's deep blue with these lyrics
deep blue let's get on a train out of
town to a place that's easier to get
around to a place that's easier to get
along to pretend to be strong deep blue
and yes Loki and Sylvie will be trying
to get out of town on a train in this
episode to a place that is literally
falling apart now on this time Jump it's
now dark outside there's actually a
plane flying in the night sky outside
C20 starts to snap out of it but Sylvie
grabs her hand because her enchantment
power Works through physical contact now
back in Haven Hills we see how Sylvie's
Crown has one of its horns broken which
is inspired from Lady Loki in the comics
but Sofia dimartino said that this
reflected Sylvie's lifetime spent on the
Run hiding in apocalypses we also see
her using it as a blunt weapon later
this episode Sylvie now infiltrates the
TBA and she passes this poster on the
wall that reads the timeline is only as
strong as its weakest moment this
episode will be Sylvia Loki's weakest
moment you might say but from the
despair of that moment they will join
hands for the first time to create their
strongest moments so really this is just
more TVA propaganda to keep lovers apart
from each other now this episode was
written by Future Miss Marvel head
writer bisha K Ali and really it's just
one of these great beats of characters
talking about their wants and their
frustrations and it's just really fun to
re-watch I think it's a super underrated
Loki episode if you ask me especially
upon rewatch when we're not that anxious
about what is going on in the show
Sylvie realizes that her magic does not
work in the TDA it catches her off guard
so this must be her first time back in
the TVA where she expected to be able to
use her powers there is a cool stunt
here though she kicks the minute man and
catches his pruning stick in the same
move and every time she proves him one
the sound effect is awesome
[Music]
yes all these Minutemen supposedly down
in the void about to be consumed by
Elias Loki grabs daggers from b15's
locker and he flips him in his hand this
is the move Tom Hiddleston originally
improvised for Thor Ragnarok after he
ran out of choreography and he brought
the move back here now these Loki
variants say to each other you're in my
way you are my way I love this line
because it's almost a declaration of
love if you think about it their duel
here is a perfectly timed synchronized
series of moves almost like a dance they
don't let go and they're still just kind
of figuring out how to dance with each
other so Loki steals Sylvie's temp pad
which leads him out of juice and
Stranded goodbye variant
now after telling Loki last episode not
to call her by his name she can't even
bring herself to say Loki now only
referring to him as variant despite that
he calls her Loki again each one really
thinks they're the main character of the
story when really both of them are or
neither of them are now that he can use
his magic again Loki teleports behind
Sylvie which is one of his favorite
tricks this is what he used to stab
Coulson in the back which is a bit
ironic because a few minutes later he
refers to himself as a consultant for
the TVA and there was a Marvel one shot
called the consultant starring Coulson
now the Tim pad has taken them to this
mining Moon called lamentis one it's the
year 2077 and lamentis one is on a
collision course for the planet and it's
about to be destroyed lamentis is
actually an outworld planet on the edge
of cree's space from the 2007
Annihilation Conquest prologue number
one comic which featured phylavel who we
saw in Guardians volume 3 taking up the
mantle of Quasar and also featured moon
dragon drax's daughter the purple hue
the planet has here could be in keeping
with its Comics appearance it would be
pretty cool to see Limited lamentis one
in the Marvel's film or at least having
that mining operations reference in some
way especially since we seem to see
another Cree mining Colony maybe that's
the planet toy that runs in the lamantis
one who knows but this doomed Moon being
named lamentis obviously connected to
the word lament it's just kind of the
emotional tone of this episode it also
reminds us of the Lars von Trier film
Melancholia which features a hidden
Planet crashing right into Earth and
really bumming out Kirsten Dunst that's
exactly kind of what the imagery looks
like with the big planet in this guy it
looked exactly like that with Melancholy
runs on Earth at the end of that Movie
Spoiler warning it's been out for 12
years or so but also this visual of
planet in the sky this is also how
incursions are depicted and the time
Runs Out storyline with Marvel Comics
The Road to Secret Wars when an
alternate Earth is shown in the sky to
represent two universes colliding I
think this era of the Multiverse and the
MCU is always better when it grounds the
story of the Multiverse in two
characters coming together and so far it
has been best in this season of Loki
like last episode ended with two Super
Storms colliding into one category eight
hurricane that hit that Alabama town
this episode shows two whole planets
colliding both of those natural
apocalypses reflect these two forces of
nature coming together two things that
should never be in the same place at the
same time now crossing paths and making
something more than the sum of their
parts now this is the only episode that
we do not cut back to Mobius or B15 back
in the TVA while this may leave you
feeling some sluggish pacing issues it
does serve to better transition this
season from a solo mission of Loki
hopping around places just grounding in
here on this one doomed planet and
redefining this series as a true
partnership a two-hander Loki asks what
exactly makes a Loki a Loki
Independence Authority
style yeah the show needs to take this
beat to answer these questions because
otherwise we would just assume variants
need to all look like Tom Hiddleston
vaguely well years in the making plan
was to tear the place down create the
ultimate power vacuum and then just
walk away
I'd never have done that I love this one
because it's exactly what ends up
happening in the finale episode Sylvie
creates a power vacuum but just walks
away from it apparently in season two to
McDonald's meanwhile Loki would have
wanted to take over the TBA in Kang's
place now this mining town incorporates
imagery from a real live Earth disaster
the town's alien letters at least the
ones high up are actually Cyrillic with
your inflates to private the name of the
town where the Chernobyl incident
occurred on the right are these words
which also refers to some Ministry of
the USSR meanwhile using the
cryptography 101 tool of substitution
even though we don't know the fictional
alien alphabet that we see on the
buildings the one that Sylvie goes up to
probably translates to the word mining
m-i-n-i-n-g if you're looking for a more
professional way to Showcase what you do
online then links to your social media
Pages it might be time to get yourself a
website and that means it's time to
check out Squarespace Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform that provides you
with everything you need to do whatever
you need with your website Squarespace
has templates and designs for pretty
much everything so even if you're making
your very first website using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products and then save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business to
check it out for yourself head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain now Sylvie kicks open the door
of this Homestead trailer and she gets
blasted back by some instrument that I
assume was used for mining or clearing
Rockaway it visually reminds us of when
the bride tried to get the drop on bud
in his trailer and Kill Bill Vol 2 but
Loki sees a framed photo of that woman
with her husband anata Grant Woods
American Gothic he tries to use this to
trick her but it similarly blasted
because that's the thing about true love
you know when someone's bullshitting you
and we see two different approaches here
Sylvie's brute strength versus Loki's
enchantment each failing to get info
from this Homesteader
devils devils and it Harkens back to the
song Demons that opened this episode so
Sylvie and Loki make it to the train
that is taking the wealthy to the arcs
to get off the planet which definitely
seems like a nod to bang Jun ho film
snow piercer starring Chris Evans which
takes place on a train that was carrying
the last of humanity but was ultimately
divided by class an excellent film and a
Marxist allegory if this is a random
detail but two of the extras in line
that they pass are identical twins which
he's dead in The Matrix age and defense
program to show the artificiality of
that simulation when Loki disguises
himself as a train guard he leans behind
Sylvia what looks like a kind of dance
move like this whole episode is really
just these two learning how to tango
they trick their way past these guards
and these guys are listed in the credits
as private Hudson and Corporal Hicks
which were Bill Paxton and Michael
Bean's characters and James Cameron's
aliens getting on the train Loki says uh
look I can't go backwards on the train
yeah I don't know how many trains a kid
who grew up on Asgard has taken but it
indicates that he is prone to motion
sickness recalling when Dr Strange made
him fall and Ragnarok
I have been falling for 30 minutes
lookie says he learned Magic from his
mother getting a little sad thinking
about friega again and Sylvie asks what
was she like
a queen of Asgard
seems good
purely decent yeah remember freaking's
death is still fresh for this Loki since
he only learned about it from watching
that film strip in episode one so he is
in time to fully process it he shows off
some firework magic for telling the kind
of fireworks that we end this episode
with when the ark blows up meanwhile
silly confirms that she was also adopted
but unlike Loki she knew this truth from
a young age so he also says that she had
to teach herself magic which compared to
Loki who learned his magic from his
stepmother I would say makes Sylvie the
superior Loki Sylvie uses that
Homesteader as an example that love is
hate and the two debate in this episode
what the meaning of Love Is
what was that
Love Is Love is hate oh piss off how
this episode answers this question will
tell us a lot about these characters
Sylvie says manage to maintain quite a
serious long-distance relationship with
a postman whilst running across time
from one apocalypse to another yeah
there were a bunch of theories about who
this Postman might be but my favorite of
these theories is that it's a nod to the
Marvel Postman Willie Lumpkin Who's Stan
Lee actually played in a cameo in 2005's
Fantastic Four welcome back to the
Baxter Dr Richards I've got the usual
for you good to have you back sir in the
comics the character did end up time
traveling at one point Sophia demartino
said an interview that she actually
heard about all the theories and was
really enjoying them but you know she
didn't write this episode she wouldn't
know Sobe asks Loki about his love life
must have been would be princesses
or perhaps another Prince
a bit of both yes Loki confirms he is
bisexual as was the case in certain lore
and Comics appearances Sophie wakes up
to Loki singing and as guardian drinking
song the song actually starts pretty
festive which is thinking she sings come
home when she thinks she thinks come
home which when you think about it's
kind of like a viking complaining oh my
lady never see him my lady never sings
and when she sings She's singing why do
you stay out so late but then Loki gets
serious and he sings the slow sad verse
which the closed captioning actually
identifies as a language of as guardian
but the words are actually Norwegian yes
it reminds us at the moment in one
division when Wanda sang an emotional
song in a language of sokovian but
having this sad moment this lament shows
how for Loki it's not a complaint to
have a woman singing out to him to bring
him home really for him he's not a devil
he is a traveler who has been wandering
alone and he just wants a fair Maiden
who's calling him home and somewhere
deep down he thinks he has found that in
Sylvie but really the fact that he is
into her is a statement about himself
because really he has just found it in
himself this is kind of a case study a
narcissism when you think about of
course we get a call back to the cup
smashing moment in Thor
another another
and Loki tells Sylvie that he's not
drunk he's just full which is kind of an
in-joke because in Norwegian to be full
means to be drunk Loki has an answer for
Sylvie finally about the meaning of love
love
is a dagger it's a weapon
to be wielded far away or up close you
can see yourself in it
it's beautiful until it makes you bleed
But ultimately when you reach for it
it isn't real
yeah Loki is really talking about Sylvie
he sees himself in her and she's
beautiful and he's afraid that when he
finally reaches for her she won't be
real and yeah it kind of foreshadows how
Sylvie will push Loki out of the Citadel
making them weapons wheeled it up close
to each other but also far away from
each other like he did to her earlier
Sylvie makes fun of his metaphor love is
an imaginary dagger
it doesn't make sense is it and yes
illusions of daggers is an allusion to
the famous monologue of Macbeth is this
a dagger I see before me which is a
famous story about assassinating Kings
and finding their crowns to be too heavy
of a burden to bear as Sylvie will find
in this season when she kills the king
he remains and yes we see still be using
her crown as a weapon which Loki did in
Thor Ragnarok and her sword has these
runes similar to the ones on mjolnir and
Stormbreaker but while those actually
translate to real things this kind of
looks like a gibberish mixture of
younger and Elder futhar Loki is thrown
from the train and he lands in the same
position that he did when hitting the
sancta floor in Ragnarok and the same
way he did last episode when he got
tossed by that so we possessed trucker
it's really a signature Landing move at
this point there's a weird detail right
here when he lands he's still wearing
his variant jacket but a moment later
when he stands up and walks towards
Sylvie the jacket is gone we don't see
where it went and look if you don't want
it can I have it because I wasn't on the
Press list when like all those
influencers got those cool looking
jackets I want one my guess is that
there was a scene here that was cut like
maybe a meteorite caught Loki's jacket
on fire and they just didn't have time
to finish the VFX of it look he reveals
that the Tim pad was broken when he
landed and Sylvie screams in frustration
lets out a shock wave of green sorcery
similar to Wanda's red sorcery blast
it's also reminiscent of the moment Loki
learns of his mother's death and Thor
the Dark World when he blasted the
furniture away these two are variants so
it would make sense that their emotional
Tantrums produce similar results we end
this episode on this three minute winner
through the collapsing city of shuru and
while it looks like there is not a
single cut in here nope there actually
is eight or nine shots cleverly stitched
together through hidden cuts on whip
pans or when things past the front of
the frame or just VFX tilts whatever it
is but this town was built practically
on a Backlot they are actually running
around all these city blocks it's pretty
fun to watch Hiddleston and demartino
run around like this and you can tell
it's a 360 degree set and they actually
use black light paint that would create
new reflective light sources for the
actors at night so they wouldn't have to
have a lighting crew follow them around
the whole time it's just a pristinely
choreographed dance between two variants
who are for once perfectly in sync
they've never been better when the world
is collapsing around them so Loki and
Sylvie walk through this tunnel into all
the chaos and the camera pushes in
behind them to follow along almost like
it's is trying to keep up Loki steps on
this barrier admits the chance of let us
on and then we get our first cut as two
people run across the frame cut and then
the camera follows Loki and Sylvie down
an alley and then rotates with them as
they turn kind of feels like they had a
dirty dancing with oh
but there's an explosion and a crane up
on a VFX shot of the colliding Planet
breaking in half and spraying more
meteor bits everywhere the planet
cracked down the middle makes it look
like a big old mouth about to Pac-Man
this city one of those bits strikes the
building and we get another hidden cut
here as the frame flashes and the more
debris causes an explosion that blows
Loki and Sylvie off their feet and fills
the frame with smoke we get our next cut
as we hear that ringing tinnitus effect
like it's saving forever Ryan but Loki
gives Sylvia a hand and they run into a
cafe and they work together to fight
some guards and I assume here that they
might have been using their stun actors
and on the other side of it we get
another cut as the camera pass it's a
beam and they run out of the cafe we're
back to Hiddleston and dimartino falling
Rebel blocks their way so they take
cover with some locals and then we
follow a running woman and we get our
next cut as the top of a building
collapses Loki uses telekinesis to stop
a building from squishing them and then
we cut on this whip pan it's not that
fast of a whip pan but if you look
closely at Loki's body from two
different shots they are layered on top
of each other just barely overlapping
it's actually pretty well done from a
VFX standpoint but the final combination
of moves they do are actually mirrored
dance moves shove to the side same block
same punches and same leg sweep and then
both are grabbed from behind so why does
this long tracking shot this Warner work
why have the black light paint other
than to provide a light source
thematically it's because this is our
Silver Linings Playbook rom-com episode
it's a love hate team up learning to
dance and the town of shuru is really a
dance club at the end of the world you'd
expect to see Zemo rocking out in the
background somewhere because our lovers
have learned to tango and the arc gets
wrecked right before their eyes not only
are Loki and still be defeated both the
panicked residents of shuru and the
guards stop in their tracks everyone
United in despair as Sylvie walks away
and defeat we hear Bonnie guitars 1957
song Dark Moon which has these lyrics
Mortals have dreams of Love's perfect
schemes but they don't realize that love
will sometimes bring a dark moon away up
high up in the sky a reminder that Loki
and Sylvia as much as they like to call
themselves gods or demigods they are
Immortals and that they're coming
together and this loving Embrace is
actually part of a scheme the end
credits have been updated once again but
the images are now moving by faster than
previous episodes we see black and white
photos of Loki and Sylvie together from
their exploits in this episode showing
how quickly the TVA is capable of
updating their records so our breakdown
of episode 4 the Nexus event is coming
next and we found more great stuff in
that episode so be sure to check that
out when it drops subscribe to all three
channels on the new rockstars Network
big thanks to Gina ippolito for writing
this free breakdown you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for breakdowns of everything Loki thanks
for watching bye
foreign
[Music]